rasante sportwagen spiele um hohe
einsätze missionen an exotischen orten
und kämpfe gegen schurken mit
massenvernichtungswaffen sind seine
markenzeichen
borg transport mit der lizenz zum töten
was kaum bekannt ist 007 schöpfer ian
fleming ex agent und journalist nutzte
insiderwissen über echte spionage
operationen des kalten krieges am
berliner todesstreifen berlin wurde in
den frühen 1960 er jahren immer mehr zum
schlafen gradmesser für die spannungen
zwischen ost und west 2 welt die
theologien und ihre spione breiten hier
an einer grenze direkt aufeinander
es war angst einflößend ehrlich gesagt
es war ernüchternd die mauer zu sehen
mit den befestigungen wachtürmen und
wachsoldaten
ein bond abenteuer der original bücher
für den berühmtesten agenten der welt
kurz vor dem mauerbau auf eine
scharfschützen mission an die deutsch
deutsche grenze
die berliner mauer ist später auch
schauplatz eines 007 kinofilms bei den
dreharbeiten kommt es zu mysteriösen
zwischenfällen zehnte august 1982 in
berlin
es laufen dreharbeiten für den bond film
octopussy aus der sowjet zone wird die
filmcrew beobachtet von
ddr-grenzsoldaten dem 007 spielt damals
der brite roger moore einer der
berichten kann was dann geschah wird auf
frankfurt besuch stilecht vorgefahren
von james bond club deutschland in einem
aston martin db5 der brite john glenn
ist der regisseur der die bond filme der
80er jahre prägte er erinnerte sein team
ob in berlin dennoch den schauer des
todesstreifens spürte es war ziemlich
ernüchternd die mauer zu sehen mit den
befestigungen wachtürmen und den
wachsoldaten dazu all die berichte dass
man menschen erschossen hatte
die versuchten von ost nach west zu
fliehen ich wurde mit einer kleinen crew
zum checkpoint charlie und räten eine
szene am checkpoint und obwohl wir die
ostdeutsche polizei informiert hatte
dass wir kommen war ihnen bestimmt nicht
klar was genau dafür einige bestürzte
gesichter wenn man deutscher muss sich
dem checkpoint charlie näher an leicht
haben
bitte dass auch das letzte sein können
was wir von ihm sehen also waren wir
vorsichtig weil wir nah an der mauer
finden
eine action szene wird bei
abenddämmerung im niemandsland direkt an
der mauer getreten der als clown
kostümierte bonn kollege 009 flieht
darin aus einer zirkustruppe die an
einer sowjetische nuklear verschwörung
beteiligt ist agent 009 hat aufgedeckt
dass der ost zirkus nur tarnung ist um
auf einem kommenden gastspiel im westen
eine atombombe zu zünden
ein messerwerfer atz sich in
sowjetischen verschwören gehört setzt
seinem fluchtversuch über die berliner
grenze ein tödliches ende gedreht wurde
das nachts auf der westseite als glam
seinen kamerakran an der mauer hoch
schwenkt und auf den todesstreifen nach
osten filmt werden ddr grenzsoldaten auf
einem wachturm nervös wir hatten einen
großen kran der über die mauer erreicht
so dass die kamera das niemandsland
zwischen ost und west filmte mit all den
grenzbefestigungen stacheldraht und all
dem die ddr soldaten hatten fotoapparate
deren blitzlichter blitzten alle paar
sekunden auf die fotografierten was wir
taten und werden gerätselt haben was in
aller welt wir wohl floriert die grenze
zu wichtig ist ihnen dieselben
möglichkeit den todesstreifen zu treten
bevor die bond film vorab reist kommt es
zu einem mysteriösen vorfall filmkopien
des drehtages am todesstreifen
verschwinden aus einem berliner
kopierwerk regisseur len vermutet dass
die kommunistischen machthaber in ost
berlin und moskau dahinter stecken
wir hörten gerüchte dass die einzigen
james bond filme die in russland gezeigt
wurden im kreml waren die dinge davon
aus dass man im kreml die filme schaute
weil sich darin gut die westliche
haltung gegenüber russland widerspiegelt
es bleibt spekulation ob die gestohlenen
filmkopien im moskauer kreml begutachtet
wurden
wollte man nach dem zwischenfall an der
ddr-grenze wissen was genau der 007 dreh
über die anlage des todesstreifens
verriet oder wollte man sehen wie die
film schuppen der ost mächte dargestellt
sind
immerhin war in jenem august 1982 die
populärste agenten figur des westens auf
berlin mission zweifellos gelangte das
verschwundene material nach moskau
und das hat sie hoffentlich amüsiert wir
haben immer versucht die russischen
bösewichte mit humor darzustellen
wir schrieben für sie recht lustige
szenen in einem bond-film zeigten wir
den chef des kgb das war bei in
tödlicher mission
es war jene zeit des kalten krieges in
der wir unseren beitrag zur klassen aus
entspannung leisten
wir setzen eine schöne frau eine ex miss
world auf den schoß des kwb generals
gogol während der telefonierte ich habe
das ins drehbuch aufgenommen um die
russen menschlich darzustellen
für die sowjets war kunst teil eines
kulturkampfes dass der held einer
antisowjetischen filmreihe sehr
erfolgreich war mussten sie deshalb
bekämpfen
nach dem mysteriösen verschwinden der
film kopien ihres
hinterlässt die james bond film crew am
ort des zwischenfalls mit den ddr
grenzern einen trotzigen abschiedsgruß
007 war hier auf mission an die berliner
grenze hatte bonn schöpfer ian fleming
seine agentin figur schon über 20 jahre
zuvor entsandt in einem flieger um
scharfschützen bei einer ddr flucht
hinter der wahre ereignisse des kalten
krieges stecken in der kurzgeschichte
der hauch des todes versucht bond als
scharfschütze einen anderen
scharfschützen auszuschalten der die
flucht eines überläufers in den westen
verhindern soll
flemming beschreibt das niemandsland
zwischen ost und westberlin wundervoll
detailliert bis hin zu den unkräutern
die dort wachsen beobachtungen die auf
einen berlin-besuch flemings im mai 1960
berühmt
der einstige weltkriegs agent war mit
seinen 007 schülern zum bestseller autor
geworden durch deutschland tourt er mit
seinem neuen fortan wird das 59er modell
mit einem damals neue art
sieben liter motor leistungsstark und
dabei relativ leise ihn kaufte autos aus
bestimmten gründen wegen eines
besonderen motors oder ich meine der 290
ps der war schwarz es war ein sender
wird mit oscar und deckt komplett runter
machen konnte er hat mal was geschrieben
über das das klicken des kilometerzähler
es eigentlich so schön ist wie das
umschlagen von buchseiten und er hat
sozusagen das fahren mit allen sinnen
genossen und in der hinsicht gibt es
eine parallele auch james und der genuss
aus seinen bentley java battleship
gehäuse ließ der damals in briesen real
so schlachtschiff grau aber es waren
sozusagen als auch immer so arrangierte
waren das ist weil es keine limousinen
oder so dann die hatten schon richtig
dampf unterm hintern und waren was
besonderes für die damalige zeit auf den
straßen
für die sunday times schreibt fleming
einer reportage über großstädte der welt
darunter berlin
immer hält er ausschau nach ideen für
neue bond abenteuer
was sie auszeichnet auch heute noch
finde ich dass er erstens immer sehr
sehr gut recherchiert hat kapstadt
blinde gesammelt einspeise karten
gesammelt und unterlagen über städte
gesammelt wie die verhältnisse waren
nun geht man zum beispiel weg womit man
dann hin kaffeemarkt war einer der orte
wo man dann hingegangen ist auch
siegessäule und verschiedene andere
bereichert das sich angesehene
gedächtniskirche und so um dann auch
gleich mal für die notwendigen
informationen zu und fakten zu sorgen
damit die geschichte glaubwürdig ist
also und der hintergrund spielt für
flemming waren mit berlin auch dunkle
erinnerungen verbunden kriegs befehle
die von der hauptstadt des einstigen
deutschen reiches ausgingen hatten seine
familie schwer getroffen
er machte dort schlägt bei berlin hatte
ihn aber etwas gemischte gefühle dieser
zwiespältigen wohl damit zusammen dass
er seinen vater im ersten weltkrieg
verloren hatte und seinen bruder im
zweiten welt
auf seinen 007 überträgt fleming in der
berlin kurzgeschichte ähnlich düstere
erinnerungen an die stadt
james bond empfand berlin als
bedrückende feindliche stadt die auf
westlicher seite mit schnellem anstrich
lackiert und billig aufpoliert war
flemings nichte kate sieht weitere
biografische ähnlichkeiten zwischen
ihrem onkel ihn und seine schöpfung
james bond gehen konnte deutsch sprechen
er lernte es als junger mann ende der
1920 er jahre hatte er eine zeit lang in
münchen studiert und sich dort sehr wohl
gefühlt und in der geschichte der hauch
des todes als bond auf seinen einsatz
als scharfschütze wartet liest er einen
deutschen thriller also auf deutsch
daher wissen wir dass james bond auch
deutsch spricht
flemings karriere im britischen marine
nachrichtendienst endete 1945 ab ende
der 40er jahre arbeitet er in london für
eine große zeitungsgruppe darunter die
sunday times als foren manager
koordinierte ein weltweites netzwerk von
über 80 auslandskorrespondenten er
organisierte das ähnlich wie damals als
er geheimdienstkoordinator bei der
marine war er saß ganz oben im zeitungs
gebäude
da hat er eine sehr große weltkarte
hängen da waren 80 kleine lichtpunkte
drauf von all seinen agenten oder
korrespondenz man es nennen möchte und
die leuchte die schickten ihm
informationen wie er es nannte
das waren nur auslandsreportagen die er
dann in verschiedenen zeitungen
platzieren allerdings arbeiteten einige
seiner journalisten zugleich für den
auslandsgeheimdienst mi6 das ein
bisschen so als wäre das sein
persönliches netzwerk an korrespondenten
gedankenstrich und es gibt ein foto von
ihm am schreibtisch in seinem londoner
zeitungs büro und hinter ihm sieht man
eine weltkarte mit markierungen die die
standorte aller auslandskorrespondenten
anzuzeigen
das ist fast so als wäre er eine
schurken figur aus der wand welt weiter
kontrollieren ein großes weltweites
imperium
flemming konnte sich auch wie ein
geheimdienstchef fühlen einige seiner
korrespondenten waren zugleich als
britischer agenten aktiv darunter seien
man in deutschland internet terry der
arbeitet parallel für den
auslandsgeheimdienst mi6 jagd nazi
kriegsverbrecher und informationen zur
nuklearen aufrüstung des ostblocks
fleming s über das doppelleben terrys im
bilde und nutzt es für seine bond
abenteuer
mai 1960 fleming lässt sich von seinem
mann in berlin hinter die touristischen
fassaden führen zu den echten spionage
geschichten des kalten krieges auch in
die sowjetische zu wenn fleming wissen
wollte was hinter dem eisernen vorhang
vorging und was im sowjetischen sektor
von berlin passierte
terry macht ihn sogar mit einem echten
ost spielen zusammen der über die
berliner grenze hinweg operierte für
flemming waren das magische geschichten
die er insbesondere in seinem späten 007
thriller der hauch des todes
verarbeitete diese ganzen politischen
spannungen in berlin
in seinem reisebericht für die sunday
times anonymisiert fleming den ost
spieler nennen wir nur ein berüchtigter
mittelsmann der seine informationen für
jeden betrag verkauft den irgendeiner
der westlichen geheimdienste breites zu
zahlen so soll ostdeutsche und
sowjetische informanten und überläufer
rekrutieren um überläufer kgb geschichte
die er in der hauch des todes beschreibt
könnte flemming von einem echten spion
gehört haben
wir können aber nicht ganz sicher sein
woher er das hatte aber als fleming bei
anthony terry in berlin war brachte
terry ihn mit einem spion zusammen der
die sowjets auskundschaftet damals war
die stadt in vier sektoren geteilt und
es kam zu waghalsigen flucht über die
grenze
die amerikaner und briten hatten einen
tunnel gegraben um telefonkabel im osten
anzuzapfen
es ist also möglich dass flemming von
einem agenten hörte dem es gelungen war
durch das niemandsland zwischen beiden
seiten zu fliehen
flemming lässt sich den
deutsch-deutschen grenzstreifen entlang
der zimmerstraße zeigen und das haus der
ministerien der ddr im wiedervereinten
deutschland sitzt darin heute das
bundesministerium der finanzen
damals ist der 007 schöpfer beeindruckt
von der atmosphäre des nachkriegs berlin
in einer zeitungs reportage beschreibt
er sein schlüsselerlebnis
es wirkt wie eine trümmerwüste was fans
das wirtschaftliche zentrum berlin zwar
in der finalen schlacht um die stadt
wurde es dem erdboden gleichgemacht
die volkspolizei ist hier in schussweite
spionage groß im geschäft in berlin
titel seine im august 1960
veröffentlichte reportage in der es von
echten agenten nur so wimmelt auf seiner
tour entlang der sektorengrenze der
alliierten besatzungsmächte war der bond
autor dem schlagabtausch der spione des
kalten krieges so nahe gekommen wie noch
nie berlin wurde in den frühen 1960 er
jahren immer mehr zum scharfen
gradmesser für die spannungen zwischen
ost und west weil die beziehung zwischen
den vier mächten die in berlin die
besatzer waren hier besonders
augenfällig wurde jede seite die es für
nötig hielt konnte hier ihre stärke zur
schau stellen
auch gab es ein echtes problem den
genauen grenzverlauf festzulegen
die sowjetunion so ostberlin als
mittelamerika zu demütigen unter druck
zu setzen und den usa zu signalisieren
hört mal wenn ihr in kuba einmarschiert
dann werden wir euch hier probleme
verursachen dreizehnter august 1961
wenige monate nach den us gesteuerten
invasionsversuch auf dem kommunistischen
kuba starten moskau und die ddr-führung
den bau einer
im ostberlin der ostsektor den bond
autor fleming im sommer zuvor noch
besichtigen konnte ist nun eingemauert
und mit ihm seine menschen
[Musik]
als die nachricht vom mauerbau fleming
erreicht ist der elektrisiert in wenigen
tagen schreibt er seine 007
scharfschützen thriller den lässt er im
sommer 1960 spielen genau in dem jahr
und an dem grenzabschnitt den er
besichtigt hatte des todes beginnt
eigentlich damit dass und in
großbritannien ist in einem schieß
center und bis lese außerhalb von london
untersagen auf seine schießkünste
überprüft wird und dann den auftrag
erhält von emden nach berlin zu gehen um
dort einer ein überläufer zu helfen
von ost nach west zu kommen
fleming dachte wohl wie wäre es mit
einer geschichte bei der ein
scharfschütze einen anderen
scharfschützen tötet das ist sein kern
szenario in der hauch des todes und
erfährt dass einer ihrer spione bei
nacht durch das niemandsland von ost
nach west fliehen will doch ein kgb
schütze will den fliehenden töten also
soll und den kgb killer ausschalten der
in einem gebäude auf ddr seite vermutet
wird
bond lauert auf westseite er vermutet
einen heckenschützen des sowjetischen
kgb hinter den fenstern im haus der
ministerien der ddr direkt östlich der
grenze
der kgb will verhindern dass der
überläufer mit seinem wissen über
sowjetische nuklear waffen in den westen
flieht der gefährlichste teil der flucht
strecke liegt mitten zwischen den
schützen
die grenze verläuft 1960 durch
niemandsland über eine straße für die
überläufer eine todeszone von 30 metern
den schauplatz hatte fleming akribisch
recherchiert sehr konkret gesagt was für
fahrzeuge stehen dort vor der tür
wie muss ich mir die ganze umfeld
vorstellen die höchsten etagen und sehr
detailliert diese kataloge sich angelegt
um darüber zu darüber schreiben zu
können wenn man also diese straße
entlang gegangen ist wusste man nach 200
metern geht es links rum und in die
nächste straße
[Musik]
dort beobachtet dann diese diese person
und stellt dann fest dass der überläufer
angeworfen wird attackiert wird
auf ddr seite bringt der sowjetische
schütze seine kalaschnikow in stellung
und erlebt eine überraschung
dann nimmt die geschichte eine fleming
wendung der todesschütze ist eine sie
die schützen ist mit einer orchester
gruppe in das ddr gebäude gelangt als
cellist in getan in ihrem cello kasten
kann sie gut ihr gewehr verstecken
da hat fleming wohl an seine
stiefschwester amaryllis gedacht die
eine berühmte cellist in bar und gold
blondes haar hatte in der geschichte
kann bond das blonde haar der killerin
erkennen und gerät in eine zwickmühle
als er merkt dass die schützen ab
drücken will
er sieht die haarlocke soll er eine frau
töten
sonst hat er keine probleme damit
jemanden zu töten
aber bei einer schönen frauen ist das
für ihn schwer
als realen kern nutzt fleming den faktor
sowjetische schützinnen bei der
weltmeisterschaft im sportschießen von
1958 große medaillen erfolge gefeiert
hatten
gold ging an tamara lomo war silber an
elena toskana und bronze an riemer
salenko die sportschützen von weltklasse
waren aber keine kgb kielerinnen das war
eine zutat aus flemings fantasie
ein damaliger nachrichten film über
diese schieß weltmeisterschaft zeit nur
die männlichen schützen
mangelnde gleichberechtigung anno 1958
also die blonde cellisten in der hauch
des todes ist die scharfschützen die
bunt eliminieren soll und anstatt sie zu
töten
schießt er lediglich die waffe aus der
hand der überläufer schafft dann
erfolgreich in den westen aber bonds
auftrag war ja eigentlich klar den
scharfschützen zu töten
insofern läuft auch gefahr seine doppel
null lizenz zu verlieren und sein
britischer gehilfe sagt ihm auch klipp
und klar das ist ein verstoß gegen seine
mission wäre und dass dann
dementsprechend werden müsse sie hatten
eindeutigen befehl zu töten egal wer es
war
denken sie ich mag den job ok mit etwas
glück kostet mich das meinen doppelnull
status
also er hat er auch schon so ein stück
weit vielleicht sogar damit
abgeschlossen mit dieser rolle als als
agent mit der lizenz zum töten
dies ist die weniger bekannte düstere
seite des original bond nur drei jahre
vor seinem tod zeigt fleming den von ihm
erschaffenen agenten als gebrochene
persönlichkeit unter der last der lizenz
zu töten sucht sein später 007 zuflucht
in schlaftabletten alkohol und zweifelt
am sinn des agenten das 1
echte inspiration für bund missionen gab
ein weiterer spionagefall an der
berliner grenze journalist fleming
erlangte insiderwissen über die flucht
eines sowjet agenten aus ost berlin im
august 1961 kurz vor dem mauerbau der
fall des kgb überläufers bogdanski
staschewski war ein ukrainer der
zeitweise in ost berlin lebte rekrutiert
hatte ihn die abteilung 13
eine sektion des kgb die darauf
spezialisiert war feinde des kommunismus
außerhalb der sowjetunion zu töten diese
hatte auch zugang zu allen möglichen
üblen tricks des kalten krieges wie
menschen zu ermorden ohne spuren zu
hinterlassen
abteilung 13 entwickelte solche waffen
in ihrem speziallabor in russland auch
die kammer genannt die kammer war ein
absolut furchterregender ort so
gefürchtet dass die eigenen techniker
nicht gerne dort herumliefen
weil da auch alle möglichen giften
entwickelt wurden
der sowjet geheimdienst hatte den
ukrainer schinski mit 19 jahren
zwangsrekrutiert die sowjets toten
seiner anti kommunistisch eingestellten
eltern sonst in ein gulag straflager zu
schicken
verschiedenste operierte ende der 50er
jahre aus ostberlin den stadtteil
karlshorst und der hielt der kgb seine
größte zentrale außerhalb der
sowjetunion unscheinbar in einem
ehemaligen krankenhaus der militärische
hochsicherheitsbereich es im lokalen
jargon auch berliner kreml von den ost
agenten haben sich in stasi akten fotos
von ihren waffen und gadgets jener zeit
erhalten anfang 1957 erhältst schinski
vom kgb den auftrag einen in münchen
lebenden ukrainischen separatisten zu
eliminieren
mit einer spezial waffe bogdan wurde
rekrutiert um einen mann namens lepad zu
ermorden
ein anti sowjetische eingestellter
intellektueller den moskau loswerden
wollte sie gaben schinski etwas was wie
ein zusammensetzt bares spielzeug wirkte
wie ein james bond gadget das war ein
metallrohr in dem eine etwa 20
zentimeter lange glas ampulle mit
blausäure drinsteckt
und wenn man den abzug drückte wurde die
säure als giftiger dampf ins gesicht des
opfers zerstört
die observierte red und lauerte ihm in
einem haus in münchen auf der treppe auf
als robert hoch gegen kaczynski mund
geht als sie sich begegneten zog er
diese waffe aus seinem anzug drückte den
abzug und sprühte das gift den opfer
direkt in 22 sekunden später sagte
robert zusammen gestorben an einem
herzinfarkt
das schönste hatte zum eigenen schutz
ein gegengift geschluckt der gift rick
flog erst auf als er ihn im jahr 1959
wieder in münchen bei einem weiteren
ukrainischen dissidenten namens bandera
anwender bei der autopsie entdeckten sie
diesmal glassplitter auf dem gesicht des
opfers und spuren der blausäure im magen
tasci hatte unterdessen eine ostdeutsche
geheiratet die ihn zur flucht vor dem
kgb überredet am 12
august 1961 den tag vor dem mauerbau
fliegt das paar über ost berlin mit
einem gefälschten pass gelang der sowjet
keller durch ddr kontrollen über die
s-bahn schönhauser allee in den westen
der überläufer hat großes glück nur ein
paar stunden später ist die grenze für
den mauerbau abgeriegelt staschewski
stellt sich der polizei bleibt aber für
seine morde ungewöhnlich kurz in haft
die cia ist an seinem kgb wissen
interessiert und verschafft dem
ex-kieler eine neue identität
kaczynskis gift pistolen attentate
dienen bond schöpfer fleming als direkte
inspiration für seinen letzten 007
thriller der mann mit dem goldenen colt
darin zeigt er seinen agenten in
ungewöhnlicher verfassung 007 war in
gefangenschaft des kgb geraten
in der sowjetunion hat man ihn umgedreht
gegen ende wird bonn zu einer sehr
düsteren figur wenn wir ihn wiedersehen
in der mann mit dem goldenen colt ist er
ein manipulierter man die sowjets haben
ihm eine gehirnwäsche verpasst uns
beinahe tötet er in bonn berichtet
seinem geheimdienstchef die russen
hätten ihn gut behandelt und würden den
weltfrieden anstreben versteckt trägt er
jedoch eine kgb gift pistole bei sich
und konfrontiert seinen boss m
sie haben ihr ganzes leben lang gegen
irgendjemanden krieg geführt und die
meiste zeit meines erwachsenenlebens
haben sie mich als werkzeug benutzt was
wäre ein anfang wenn die kriegstreiber
eliminiert werden können bond agiert wie
ferngesteuert und schießt blausäure auf
seinen chef
frei nach dem echten gift killers
kaczynski
er versuchte mit einer pistole zu töten
wie die von strawinsky der kgb killer
war klar flemings vorlage entkommt dem
tod auf höchst ungewöhnliche weise per
knopfdruck schießt in letzter sekunde
eine glasscheibe dazwischen die ganze
säure klatsch dagegen selbst diese
unwahrscheinlich wirkende szene hat also
ihren kern fakten die kinofilme sparen
bonns gift attentat aus einen psychisch
gebrochenen 007 der zum landesverräter
wird galt für die kinokasse wohl als
nicht populär genug hinter den uhr bond
aus ian flemings spionage romanen
stecken auch wahre agenten dramen des
kalten krieges wichtige inspirationen
gewann der bond schöpfer am einstigen
berliner todesstreifen durch waghalsige
fluchtversuche echter spione und real
existierende killer agenten die im
geteilten deutschland operierten
illegale mittel wurden auf beiden seiten
des eisernen vorhangs eingesetzt auch
die berüchtigte lizenz zum töten
[Musik]